we're switching things up a bit it's hot
out there humid of course people still
stressed about Co vid and all the rest
so I thought maybe we should just get
together and kind of chill people out
with something we call summer s'mores
with Conan and of course the chill chums
wow that's great Matt what a great laugh
that's not that is not the laughs that
is not the laugh of the demeanor or the
demeanor of a chill Chum that was
horrible I think you're forgetting the
premise of this Sonia and I are the
children's and we teach you to be chill
and take it from a chill Chum that's a
chill Chum chuckle yeah okay well I
chafe at your chill Chum chuckle yeah I
I I don't like it I and also I resent
this whole idea that I'm the uptight you
know type a you know Grinch I think that
I'm very capable of being Zen hmm and
doing my Buddha belly breathing I think
I I think I exude calm well the fact
that you resent this means that you're
not very chill because the chill Tim
would just let it you know blow over
them yeah but you really great when
yours they're sitting there going hey be
a chill Chum and I can see you because
we're on a zoom call right now and I can
see that you have banjos behind you and
you have four banjos I'm counting them
and you have an array you haven't or you
have an array of tweed hats with
feathers in them tie with a vintage
guitar and a bust of Teddy Roosevelt
behind you know the bust of Teddy
Roosevelt was torn down was rip sound by
some protesters got into my house and
tore down my bust of Teddy Roosevelt
and by protesters I mean my two children
my daughter my son came in a door down
let's not start this with animosity this
being a chill Chum is all about being
friends I know you're you're already
like breaking all kinds of chill rules
yeah well you're like chill your chill
factor zero man you're the opposite of
chill if we come into this chill you
like D chill us you just got your heat
miser just chill man you know it's nice
to have to chill chums that just tell me
everything that's wrong with me
garage me with criticism that really
does help create an environment hey man
hey man